hey there fellow townscapers and welcome
back to my channel
if this is your first time here i want
to give you a big welcome and thank you
for coming by today
please do me a favor and hit that like
button and share this video to other
people that you think may enjoy the
content this will help me out a whole
lot and i would really really appreciate
it um so today i just wanted to show you
the tour for chapter four of connecting
small towns
i will start uploading chapter five
later this week but i hope you all
enjoy chapter four i was supposed to
practice cranes but i got distracted and
just kind of got lost in the build and
kind of just let things flow but before
we get started i wanted to thank you all
for coming by this week and checking out
chapter four and showing me some love
i really really appreciate it and
chapter four did really really well um
so thank you again
if you enjoy my work and you're looking
for other ways to support me for free
you can do so by clicking on the links
down below in the description one link
will simply direct you back to my home
page
just click the link and once you're on
my page you have helped me out also
if you have the brave browser you can
support me by viewing my videos via
braid
if you don't have the browser and you
would like to support me this way the
link is also in the description
it's pretty easy all you have to do is
download and install
and open my channel on the browser and
watch my videos and you will be helping
me out as well
so i thank you guys again so much for
stopping by
i really really appreciate the love
y'all are showing me and now we can get
down to business so
as i stated in previous episodes this
series is pretty much just me connecting
small towns while practicing
you'll be seeing me gradually improve
through the series um if you have seen
some of my footage
this video features some buildings that
you may recognize from sessions 19
through 22. if you haven't seen them or
you just want to view them again
the playlist will be in the card in the
upper right corner of the video
along with some other cards please be
sure to check those cards out
as there's some good stuff in there if
you do like it please hit the like
button subscribe and share with your
fellow youtube friends
because it'll really really help me out
anyways that's it for me
y'all know i don't really like to talk a
lot but i just want to come by and say
hello
please enjoy the video thank you for
viewing and please make this weekend a
great weekend and i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
hey that's pretty good
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey there townscaper if you're hearing
this and that means you made it to the
end i just want to thank you so much for
being
greatly appreciated make sure you hit
that subscribe button and make sure you
hit that like button
that will
the links are down in the description
below and again i just want to say thank
you so much
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you